3 oggi io e berlino giocheremo a tre
colori di pennarelli challenge di
hammond ha deciso di servire sul tavolo
abbiamo scoperto che berlino è
l'impostore quindi non potrà partecipare
alla challenge
voglio evitare a tre colori di
pennarelli con gli impostori ai
personaggi di hammond eccoci qua io oggi
sono team blues e letterari o vi mancino
ti farà cina la fa chi non ha visto le
nostre challenge presidenti tre colori
di pennarelli spieghiamo prossimamente
con noi dovremo pescare o un calore di
pennarelli a qetta dal calderone che
pieno di pennarelli freno per stare tre
penne per marelli di colori diversi e
dovremo colorare i disegni in questo
caso sono tutti i disegni among us con
questi tre colori e vedere come escono
voi dovrete votare per ogni turno se
vinco io o se vince vita ci saranno
quattro turni quindi potete scrivere di
volta in volta nei commenti
primo turno vi inserita o primo turno
vince vitale il di brand reebok corner
peccato che alla cioccolata calda
mettervi comodi e sono un bel mi piace
questo video raggiunge i 15 mila mi
piace esisterà la seconda parte di tre
affrontare
il primo turno 3 2
abbiamo il personaggio di among us con
il cappellino di natale che ha illuso e
poi come festa la navicella spaziale
degli ufo andiamo subito a pescare i
nostri tre colori prima pennarello mar
io ho preso quella più bello questo
[Musica]
secondo è che colore bello ci credo un
altro verde altro verde scuro a camuffa
e soprattutto il colore brutto vedere le
mie sono ripreso questa volta non male
anche capire come uscirà un po extra del
resto prima marrone
no non è vero anzi secondo perché tutto
il cappellino viola era ma va
vicinissimo con il rosso però
ad ora questi colori pronti a disegnare
3d un occhio dopo di allora non so se
[Musica]
sia bellissimo pronti a costruire tre
sembra un extraterrestre regala un
extraterrestre un po forma di sla i
viola con il cappello arancione votate
quale vi piace di più guardate un po
quale preferite il mio viola blu e
arancione ora quello di vitale bergvold
[Musica]
secondo round 3 che carini
e il personaggio diamo un grosso femmina
di dio
spero che vi capiti il rosary ma
pennarello bello credito si prima il
pescato dura scusi però già messo la
maschera bellissimo l'ostello prossimo
pennarelli bacione quindi forse la
potrei fare senette rosa rosa rosa rosa
o giallo restano comunque veicolo
ripagare documento come ti fai scegliere
bene scendono mai ti credo già allora ci
sta bene forse al chiodo però in giallo
arancione chiaro ha paventato
fortunatissimo se sta bene insieme a
rosa sto bene devo decidere se fare il
personaggio celeste o giallo verde si
trovano rosa 2
a me si è scaricato il pennarello
davvero tutti gli si scarica altro
mentre quello nuovo
date un po beh devo dire che rosa è
bellina sci e stupendo il mio una sorta
di verde acqua e realtà questo verde
sembra giallo quindi un po confuso che
bello come hai fatto anche qua race
votate chi vince per questo turno a vita
o vitale votate giù nei fumetti verso è
penultimo turno
abbiamo il personaggio con il minime che
tipo l'animaletto che si può prendere se
avete visto lo scorso episodio del
nostro gameplay avete visto che ho preso
sia il mini match sembra di quel figlio
che scappa capitale ho preso questo no è
no eh
[Musica]
[Applauso]
secondo così impari a pescare tutti i
colori belli nel secondo turno
adesso mi devo uscire un colore bello è
che colore è bello eh beh in effetti un
bel colore non è un vecchio che bello
bella guerra per acquisiti da anche a me
perché credo che se verde a noi il jazz
a loro piace ma è vero e bicchieri da
allora adesso visto che è uscito un
grande e bellissimo città un bel verde
scuro voglio bene ma io sono finalmente
un colore carino gialloverde celeste
contro per il lavoro marrone melilla
e allora come li caccio personaggio di
grayson hunt in qua abbiamo aggiunto
qualche dettaglio
allora iniziò di fargli vero abbiamo il
personaggio più mail celeste con le
guance a forma di cuore gialle poi c'è
il mini med giallo con le guance celeste
a forma di cuore lo stavi netto bicolor
aveva cappellino quell 8 egli sa che se
nel gioco con le due fogli le due
pantofole verna cosa ne pensate vediamo
per digitare mio invece viola in un mese
maglione di natale come si può vedere
qui con in mezzo il regalo di natale ma
poi imprevisti e le ho mangiate ora è un
maglione di natale quelli che si usano a
natale per batini segnini dove gli hanno
messo solo per dire chiaro come cappello
gli ho messo tre alberi diabete è qui
qua in testa e poi gli ho fatto il
piccolomini marco di colore diverso
arriva ora con quell occhio non sono un
occhio gigante in questo terzo round da
temi come quarto e ultimo hurrà pronti
tre il personaggio di among us quando
viene svelato se sei in più e mail o se
sei un impostore che sono tipiche fa
dopo
la prima penna rendere più portare a
impostare ok poi vai a vedere io che
prendo le sentite di tutti i colori più
belli bordo è questo maker tappo giallo
rosa è a rischio che colore
ovviamente non ci credo possa per
evitare la magnitudine e questo non mi
dire che il nostro verde vocazione lotto
pallino che lo fa tirando la renault
sapendo che io questo ci può stare
l'ultimo è ultimo un bel rosso il rosso
è nostro
rosso viola ok ok ok go correre domanda
qui sopra voleex critiche e colore
ma questo personaggio di among us quando
appare questa immagine rispondete nei
commenti vediamo chi indovina subito il
secondo da quando a quiz
qual è il rumore che fa dopo che esce
questa cosa ma come fai a scriverti dice
ci siamo pronti per l'ultima rivelazione
scopriremo chi ha vinto 3 2 una tappa
quanti colori da inizio a descrivere il
team hanno fatto di due colori arancione
e verde
poi il personaggio l'ho fatto viola con
la visiera dell'elmetto verde e la mano
sai quanti arancione put e sotto la
scritta invece mio è rosa e ammetto
anche lo smalto lo vedete poi che ho
fatto di perle fare cose vanno 8 il
costume del personaggio colorata e poi
delle saette qua insomma è un po fashion
quarto razza diamo un gatto e quindi
votate chi vinse lo vince torna quarto
round vins vitale o a rita votate giorni
cometti noi poi vedremo in base ai
vostri tutti se ho vinto io sanitario è
caldo episodio di tre colori pennarelli
among us la bella che mi piace e ora
quattro case linee su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite
si no